dylan cease going to not for his 25th
start of the year looking for his 10th
win his era just over four a lot of
strikeouts 165 of them 124 and
two-thirds he hasn't walked that many
people
that's what he's going to use the
four-seam fastball 46 plus percent of
the time the slider almost 30 percent of
the time with the curveball which is
getting better about 15 of the time of
the change up not so much
popped up high in the air that's danny
mendick at short he'll wave the arms and
make the catch on a big league pop-up if
i've ever seen one
one-two pitch is a line drive to center
field this will be luis robert making a
routine catch
the a's have scored four runs
total in the series vaughn will scoop
cease at the bag nicely done
that was an eight pitch first inning for
dylan
the southpaw cole irvin is going to be
taking on the south siders and he's
finally getting the pitch against
somebody other than the texas rangers
his last two starts pipe came against
the texas rangers but this one
against the chicago white sox they
happened to be an al central team and in
three starts against the al central our
man cole irvin 1-0 with an era under one
two and two and it's on the way here it
is and a change up is bounce to short
one hop to elvis
and he fires to first in one away and
that'll bring up
luis robert
there's a ball struck well
one-out single for robert runners at
first and second for the white sox in
this first inning will bring up eloy
jimenez
line shot to left that ball is going to
get to the wall
robert will score
abreu to third it's a double
for alloy and it's one to nothing
base is loaded for mankato
big moment here as the white sox trying
to put up a crooked number in the very
first inning
and a miss he struck him out he kept him
kept it away with a fastball and moncada
strikes out
goodwin hits a high fly ball
starling marte shaded into right center
he grabs it so cole irman minimizes the
damage the white sox get just one
moreland in the air out in the left
center
and it'll be eloy to grab it
[Applause]
swing and a miss right three that's his
first strikeout today
bouncer fair to vaughn behind the bag
and that'll do it for the a's in the
second here's danny mendick who's
playing at shortstop today a right
hander hitter and a ground ball too
short right to elvis elvis throws to
first for the out quickly one away and
that'll bring up the catcher zach
collins
hit pretty well the right but plenty of
room out there in right center with seth
brown getting back there to make the
catch
swinging a drive to right angle toward
the line brown is there he makes a
running backhanded catch and for cole
irvin it's an economical one two three
bottom of the second well sean murphy
will try to get things going for the a's
bottom third of the lineup first pitch
in the third fastball club to left hit
well back on it is jimenez at the track
at the wall goodbye sean murphy unloads
on dylan cease and he ties the game at
one creeps just over the middle and
who's waiting murph that's loud noise
kite
new strikes on the a's first baseman
make it three strikes
third punch out for dylan the a's are
trying to put together a rally against
cease as seth brown comes to the plate
kick and the one-two a swing and a miss
for the second out both have been
strikeouts here in the fourth he loads
the bases now for tony kemp
now he misses high with a fastball and
he walks a run in as moreland comes in
to score and the ace take the lead
a chop to
the shortstop mendic and the throw will
beat andrews
who settled it now here's the 1-2 pitch
mendick lines one to the right side
moncotta to second and danny comes up
big regardless of the count this will
bring up zach collins
they're loaded for cesar hernandez
pitches caesar hernandez it's lined
toward canada coming in still coming in
on the run canna grabs it
the first pitch swinging is luis robert
and cole irvin nice little changer to
open up louise rovers
chapman knocks it down picks it up
throws across in time two outs spawn
with a man on and two down
drill deep left field and it is gone
and the sox have the lead
after almost hitting it out last time in
right center this time he hit it out and
straight away left field
on the sixth chapman on the way and matt
on a break he wants a high fly ball to
left ximena's back he'll turn and watch
it fly and chapman has tied it up with
one swing in the sixth inning sometimes
uncle charlie can get a little ahead of
himself at the party and you gotta send
him home and that's exactly what matt
chapman did
the ace get a big two out hit here in a
3-3 game for matt olson
and that one is hit deep to right field
and that baby is gone there's your two
run homer dallas lean on me maybe they
hit the a's needed and it comes from
their all-star matt olsen a two-run shot
all aboard next stop pound count and
that'll bring up elvis with two on and
two out of me is leading five three in
the eighth here comes the 2-2
from the bounding ball to hernandez who
backed up and
able to throw him out
socks bat in the eighth down two
that one rolled right side
out at second chapman's throw to first
not in time as goodwin beats the throw
so it's going to be a fielder's choice
that one is hit in the air towards
center marte going back he's going to
have room and he makes the catch on the
warning track collins is on the tying
run will come up a little bit swing and
a miss he came back with the same pitch
a change up at 88 miles an hour and
hernandez strikes out now he's got to
deal with robert
as the tying run
0-2 pitch is hit in the air toward left
center it's hit pretty well marte's back
he's going to have just enough room and
he makes the catch
now here's a guy who tied up the game
the other night against the yankees jose
abreu here's a 1-1
and popped in the air shallow center
guessing it'll be martay
and
it drops
college will score
a brayer to second it's a one-run game
and it looks like elvis andrews is
injured
elbow area to the throat right there yep
it's essentially a clothesline you can
see the ball hit off of marte's glove
sanders it looks like he's gonna
stay in the game and now trailing by one
five to four do they dare
pitch to jimenez
first pitch is lined towards center mart
takes over there martay grabs it and
that's the ball game man it wasn't going
to be easy to get to the finish line
today